hey guys i'm ryan right hello i'm
veronica six-toes
you might notice something different
about me i got a bigger dick now we're
gonna check out the trailer the honest
trailer for Fifty Shades of Grey
yeah if you guys saw my review of it
you'll know that this was one of my
favorite movies of the year it is
hands-down pure cinema art at its best
it's so risque and really defies
boundaries whatever it's a piece of [ __ ]
I sorta like this yeah I like it for how
bad it is
oh wow 106 years ago fanfiction.net user
snow Queens ice dragon wrote a dirty
story on her cell phone I used to write
a lot of it oh my flatpoint you wrote it
on your very own then you turned her
kinky Twilight fan fiction into one of
the best-selling novels of all time
way to go now get ready for the film
adaptation that ended up leaving
millions of people around the world
asking is that it Fifty Shades of Grey
teenage girls around the world they
Twilight into a global phenomenon now
it's mom's turn
as the ridiculous fantasy of dating a
vampire is cast aside for the ridiculous
fantasy of being a gorgeous millionaires
pampered sex slave meet Bella Swan oh
I'm sorry I mean you know what screw it
me Bella swaahaa a cutesy nondescript
virgin who's so sweet she doesn't even
know what a plug plug is her bucks it's
a plug for your but speaking of butt
holes her world will change when she
meets the mysterious Christian Edward
Colin gray a mysterious billionaire who
runs a mysterious multinational
corporation which is mysteriously able
to function without him doing any press
hearts and flowers
that's not something enough rude what do
I know my success
seriously is a stalker
are you doing you can you see how it
controls what she eats
if do indeed the submissive will eat
regularly to maintain your health and
well-being and is an all-around
sociopath you're the complete serial
killer after that but who cares when
you've got these abs and Odie and a
really nice apartment so strap in for
all the steamy action people were
expecting from Fifty Shades of Grey like
emails texting contracts this is the
contract pretty carefully the following
of the terms of a binding contract
contract negotiations turn to page five
appendix three soft limits
non-disclosure agreements but you cannot
disclosure conditions I'm not gonna
touch you
not until I have your written consent
what clause is I broke rule seven Clause
five and tender missionary lovemaking
what the [ __ ]
let's get kinky weird epic boys guys
adult marriage man not story these
horrible lines from the book that I did
into the movie
his voice is warm and husky like dark
melted chocolate fudge caramel or
something
I feel the color
cheeks rising again I must be the color
of a Communist Manifesto his erection
Springs free holy cow holy crap he's
wearing a white shirt I flush at the
wickedness of my subconscious she's
doing her happy dance in a bright red
hue skirt the story's about a sexy
Israelis her and this life they did not
fifty sure to [ __ ] uh what does that
even mean that's not gonna come phrase
is this related to the dumb title of the
book uh worst thing night ever
I've never get laid oh just go and watch
safar no Fifty Shades of great there's
gonna be two more of these
good job world punish me show me how bad
it can be
I want you to show me the worst I'm
gonna hit you six times six laps is the
worst it gets didn't you Google bondage
earlier thanks for watching our 100
honest trailer if you'd like to see 100
war do us a favor and click that big
okay yeah the movie [ __ ] saw a movie
sucked with it a lot but what was so
appealing to me with reading the book
was the sex it's really really hot the
writing was not very good it was very
cheesy like you saw with the lines that
he should those were directly from the
book and it was it's kind of stupid but
it was like kind of like a porno book
and then the movie they didn't show that
much in it but I still thought it was
sexy still entertaining so if I was more
pulled into the characters I might have
found it a little sexy but because I
didn't really like them especially uh
Christian Grey yeah yeah there's nothing
like a bull about my favorite line who
as he runs a mysterious company
never works that Searchers that's the
one thing I did not point out in my
review was how the [ __ ] does this guy
get anything done because all he does is
like live a high life and he never seems
to really work that much does he work in
the book it is kind of mysterious in the
book too he just kind of leaves and goes
and does business and then he comes back
and I just don't see the appeal of this
guy in this world I mean he's so abusive
he's really abusive she's a virgin who
is like drawn to this mysterious man who
clearly has like some serious
psychological sexual trauma you know
what I said that the sex was the most
appealing but there was another part of
it that was very interesting at two
worlds it is to like two world just like
[ __ ] toilet but it's interesting to
read about because I've never even heard
of this before what is it called bondage
submission yeah I like someone I had an
idea of it but I didn't actually know oh
that is exists like people don't want to
actually do those kind of um yeah
exchanges oh yeah
do you watch more porn together no well
the porn will give you a great idea of
how it works and then we can read up on
it I'm like you know I'm not talking
about the actual action I was not a
submissive behavior of someone my slave
the relationship yeah there I'm
comparing different sides of the
spectrum like she's with pure and virgin
and doesn't have any experience and
she's like just a really sweet sweet
girl and then he is this totally [ __ ]
up dude but the way that they're trying
to make it work it's interesting cuz
they're negotiating the way that they're
changing for each other I think is
interesting I could see that sure I just
don't think it's right to do to a virgin
well that's because he made love to her
the first time all right that that's why
he he made love to her the first time I
know but they're so infatuated with each
other and it doesn't make any goddamn
sense I can see why she might be
infatuated with him he's like rich
mysterious douchebags and women tend to
like that in real life why does he like
her yeah she's nothing special
yeah like if she's a virgin he's drawn
to the innocence well he's also John
what's a corrupt
innocent he's also drawn to the fact
that she's not being submissive yeah so
he wants to make her submissive
something she doesn't want to be it's
it's very much an understanding
give-and-take relationship you know like
so much consideration and meaning to
their lifestyle that they chose to
embark on that's the whole point though
is how [ __ ] up it is I know and I
would love to see two more movies based
on that same executive action I wish
that the guy that wins Christian Grey
was different this wouldn't be as
annoying if there wasn't a [ __ ]
trilogy if it just ended right there
when Anastasia being like whoa this is
[ __ ] up and then the elevator closes
and that's the end of the story okay but
the fact that I know there's two more
movies coming based off that it makes me
go what man is the story shows then okay
okay okay I get it but there have been
plenty of movies that have had sequels
that you liked a lot more than you like
the first one so maybe he okay but let
me tell you something if I watch Captain
America Winter Soldier and I think it's
better than the first Captain America
that's different because it lays the
ground for something that has multiple
stories to explore this is like yo
dumbass don't go back to cut it out I
don't know what the next two ones are
about but I'm assuming they get involved
again I don't either I haven't read
those two I don't know it's just really
[ __ ] up I'm probably gonna read them
you tell me how that goes and if it
improves our sex life okay anyway guys
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out
Veronica's channel does a lot of
acoustic covers on there these days
check it out a bunch of fun stuff um you
should totally cover the crazy and love
song okay if you guys want that cover
you let her know and you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter where
we're trying to get a certain amount of
followers that way we could get product
placement pins pins are great for
anything you can put up pictures of like
your posters that cost a lot of money
but you just use a pin to put it up you
can stab people with
in the eye in case they're trying to
attack you and if you're really into
some Fifty Shades of Grey [ __ ] telling
baby
tell me we do with the tide don't tell
me no oh you put into your mouth and now
I'm curious you have you have going on
your head no come on like you know you
put it in your mouth like this mm-hmm
with the needle funny and then you know
you do stuff with the needle you're
discussing I'm like oh and then you're
like that's not the safety word baby and
I'm like I forgot the safety word and
then you keep doing it then before you
know when I was bleeding out and we had
to go to the hospital okay do you want
me to go along with this
yes you already just like play yes okay
okay yeah that was some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
we're in do it again tonight pins